this is message received
Oh a message was received
I believe it was fuck you um so uh man
again this uh this has a hot dread Oh
for peridots now crystal Jim yay yeah
yeah um I'll let you go first I'm torn
because I kind of liked her like sitting
on the fence because like I was
throughout most of it I hope this isn't
I hope this isn't a softer nicer pair
dad I hope she still maintains her
personality well then they'll still have
her yeah that's my only criticism is
like my only worry is that I liked para
dad because she's this outsider who is
always just grumpy as fucking watching
me it ends with her on the ground
covering her yeah I'm gonna dig zagging
me hope but on but yeah they made switch
I wasn't I wasn't entirely sure is like
oh maybe she's just betraying them and
then no she she takes that yellow D down
I thought it would be at least like two
more episodes that she would come back
cuz when you see with the timing she's
I'm gonna contact yellow time and I'm
getting in contact I'm gonna tell her
what's going on everything I mean is one
of those things I'm like okay so she's
gonna be doing this eventually she'll
come back but it'll be like two or three
episodes I like by the way how epic this
whole crystal gem like world is in these
giant beings and like it feels like
mythic and legendary and yet when they
talk it's like some inane bureaucracy
just like state your name who are you
give me the phone give on a diamond
phone like listen here you you got a job
did I'm like it's all still works like
Jupiter said I don't you know it really
works like I get a show this bureaucracy
showing how small they really are in the
grand scheme of things but it also shows
how much these small people can do and
that's why I like you have people are
small literally in size and then small
in um you know there's a list of beings
affect the outcome Frodo well I really
love those stories I really do um I like
it when they're done well I like when
they really show a legitimate threat and
cuz we seen this all the time over there
nothing they can yeah they're just you
know so miniscule and we've seen what
miniscule people can do and what you
know they can do when they can get
others together and they can inspire and
they can you know special with their
that we've seen that a lot so I still
love stories like that that's why I
still watch Game of Thrones cuz all like
the strategy and everything like I don't
give a shit what's going on with Tyrion
what's going on with Arya what's going
on with Daenerys like those are in the I
always read the female Knight wherever
she is those are all like the underdogs
the outsiders that's it
fuck you and I'm gonna do something
awesome and they're always doing
something whatever dude we all know
Stannis is gonna win so is it is no so
um yeah I thought there was a good
feeling of dread here a good you know
serv not entirely milling what she's got
to do but it's is it strange to say
there is a part of me that just I don't
want to eat with peridot but just with
something I want to see where it's like
you don't know what side they're gonna
turn and then they turn to bad and they
never come back you know I so rarely see
it the only time that they're bad
doesn't sound movie ticket does the only
time that I was getting those ratings it
was a later Simpsons episode where Marge
tastes like this criminal is trying to
rehabilitate rehabilitate himself and be
better and he's just you don't know it
yet but he's constantly lying Tory's
saying he wants to get better and then
he'll just go like light a fire or
something and she'll be yet the branch
is like that you said you were gonna try
change everything says Marge I'm not
gonna lie I did not set that fire
I saw you set that fire Marge I'm not
gonna lie
oh it just sends him off it's one of
those things where it's like as tough as
a lesson as that is it's one of those
things where it's like I think there's I
think there is good and everybody and
everybody can change but the likelihood
of sometimes we're just fucked up well
not the likelihood of big land change ed
doesn't mean they're going to yeah just
because you can do something doesn't
mean that they're going to do I think
everyone has their amount of time that
they can change
good or bad it is there enough time in
this lifespan you know like you know it
could take a hundred years for someone
to change and they live that long maybe
but we're fucked we know rare yeah I
mean there's no changing elves were just
assholes but it's one of those things
where yeah he's ruined us I think
because we are raised on so many shows
and stories and stuff that say people
can change for the good
yes they can they don't always end
people watching at home I think everyone
has had to go through an experience
where you guys it takes somebody really
close and be like I was like you're not
a savior
I feel like I see that lesson way more
in foreign films and anime hmm um I just
wanna enter a lot I just accept that
there's a lot in anime but I feel like
I've seen it more where it's as like on
others getting an asshole like oh if I
was gonna be good enough fuck you like I
feel like I've seen that more in that
room you're right I don't see it as much
in American television or if they do
change they usually come back eventually
even if it's a you know I think of like
Zuko and avatar like you know he did
change that but then like it took a
while pretty much half a season for him
to come back um
so it's one of those things where it's
like it's it's a hard lesson I think
it's an important lesson honestly uh
teach children not to trust it well see
that's the hard part is that it's just
it's experience it's it's gonna be
different for everybody and some people
have an incredible tolerance and
incredible patience and can see that
good can get that good out of people
that nobody else can but it's like wow
Zeebo do the wound is cruel but what is
we don't talk about you everyone is
gonna have someone that they cannot
change over that they cannot bring back
Doug's happy show fun hour you would
like to see this show oh my I think it's
healthy to know that it's like just
because you couldn't doesn't mean a
somebody else can take it's never true
evil exacts
fuck up just because you can't change
somebody over doesn't mean a somebody
else can and be that so you made me
forget my be um no purpose for all for
all of my ranting I actually would
totally watch
fucking to me no I I think it's
something where it just because you can
doesn't mean somebody else can't
possibly win a fag and it doesn't mean
it's gonna be done in the amount of time
that you know you're gonna be alive you
know it's one of those things where it's
like there is good and everybody that
doesn't mean you're always gonna get to
it yeah we're all sinners and we're all
doomed I think moving on know if it's
nothing to know when it's healthy to
know is that going to do that when to
move on and how much is this person
taking more from you than you're giving
to them if that makes sense
um it does so I just don't know how you
make a kid showing that seven-year-olds
bullshit it's not just sound you're all
do you know it's not okay seven to
thirty seven there you go um but uh I
really thought like yellow diamond was
legitimately intimidating and I love
that I love how big she is I love the
way she does you know her profile she
don't Lance over to look very well yeah
very snooty and definitely intermitting
but in that bitchy boss sort of way just
like I am your superior do what I say oh
uh yes but there's also the sense like
especially when you see how peridot is
you know cowering before and she's
diving in the same room but she's just
cowering before this giant you see how
big she is kids you know how big pearl
is and there's another pearl there
apparently they don't know every single
pearl um I thought that was funny uh
foyer was something racial they're like
yeah I Kappa L don't look alike we all
don't know each other um but yeah it was
something where when she did get
legitimately angry was you know ooh like
you just feel like she can she can wipe
out this player she can bring a ward she
can do something because I like that she
has not only the sides because what was
Jasper was the one that came down I was
also huge and then God um she's at the
bottom of the ocean now or whatever was
at the naval is it Jasper seven in the
giant yellow one that came down the
first big battle or whatever I ever it
was you know which that was a while ago
watch it she had the size but you know
she's a babe she's approached he's a
thug she's a you know bully uh we're I
think with this one there's just this
intimidation there's just this you know
cloud about her that's just like you
know no
you are beneath me I could snap you I
mean real people with power don't shout
that's always the Lenape I feel like I
feel like it's the Emperor from Return
not the Emperor from the prequels that
was stupid but the emperor from Return
of the Jedi where you just had this
feeling of immense power I couldn't need
to do yeah and it because we're so clean
SN that chair but yeah you just felt
yeah if you just want to be you die yeah
which is kind of how it went down at the
very end he starts throwing up points
his finger is that yeah they're fighting
with lightsabers Caesar fuck this yeah
um so yeah I talk about ya know I think
that's a good legitimate threat and even
though we've barely seen her we don't
know much about the way people react to
her and just the few choice lines in the
way she's drawn and the expressions and
the voice acting I thought that this is
a glorious event there's another
important lesson for kids besides don't
trust anyone and we all have a deep dark
sitting past um I want this show to
happen
Doug's happy be like Sean Penn's happy
for our um the other thing is always
have a back-up plan because she went
into this thinking this was gonna work
and she didn't prepare herself
emotionally well I think that's part of
a problem she thinks logic rules but she
makes the most illogical mistake ever
which is you know what I bone up shit
and you suck and I just told you that so
now we can't stall for time you're gonna
come and kick all our asses and what the
fuck did I just do
yeah well you should is we you know she
could have just like lied and been like
oh yeah sure I'll get on that turn it
off and be like well Bernard ship is
humming it I mean that was the thing is
that I feel like you just yeah but I
feel like you've lost precious stalling
in this case she's the one who's just
like every minute counts and she just
lost more precious darling minutes even
if there's no cloudy they still got to
figure out what's going on and now they
know exactly what's going on cuz she
just won this is why I like the
connection with the last episode cuz you
know she's on this emotional high where
it's like you know it's almost like she
saw her roots again and she wanted to
turn back 10,000 everything and Sanus
for the character she had a complete
meltdown like knowing what we know about
peridot she had a meltdown and it makes
total sense but it is what those things
are I'm like no you just a youth what
one of this woman wrote all your cards
one miss opportunity when she says you
know I wear you know there's things out
here we're going to protect it I wanted
uh yo yellow crystal just a yellow
diamond just go we I wanted that bomb no
no I mean it just for all them to be
like you know crap like we just totally
out it there's more
I had a great big guard is just like oh
yeah I also really like the joke about
the detonator - somebody take his way
he'll probably explode and she just
falls on the ground not caring what's
gonna happen them just tossing about a
little forth and hitting into the L of
them hugging her and be like we're curvy
a crystal gem just um so yeah it's a
good episode
yeah good episode I'm curious where it's
gonna go and we're on toe and the the
animation we should mention yes
the a lobby expression a la Oklahoma
dynamic akhter yeah that's a hella
Fister whatever the hell that was was
one be most hilariously amazing things
as you not says dogcopter nya you know
what I'm fucking like this better than
don't have a setup is air I said it it's
better than to encounter even for Steven
universe I was like this is a nation can
be really wacky yeah no I love that the
the way the robot moved the expressions
again are wonderful in this one oh the
hood the whole car lock things yeah I
was just thinking AHA where we have the
technology of safety like oh yeah I love
her reactor - oh this is bad how could
you cage the awkward but lovable parrots
like even she's acknowledging like you
know her quirky character um all those
were good - we focused on the ending but
I forgot there's a lot of good bits of
it yeah I love it when she's in the car
they they shadow her and all you see are
the eyes and again it's like technically
that makes no sense you wouldn't be able
to see the eyes of you know a tall
shadow and sup I love again that's great
about animation you can do that and it
can just set the mood
much better and add so much more to our
character oh it is no yes
so um yeah good episode and definitely
looking forward to the last one of I
guess the season or before the hiatus I
have according to like my Wikipedia
thing it's like we're still technically
on season two but then people are
telling me it's like season three or
four I don't know but what is another
pretty even bomb coming which sounds
like some sort of goofy terrorist threat
to me but it's like all them so yeah
they call them Steven bombs or it's a
whole bunch of episodes at once oh okay
now I just imagine these little bombs
with the face of Stephen leicht but um
so yeah looking forward to it and we
will see you at the last one before the
Stephen Bob data glare